temo di essere qui per fare il
guastafeste quindi adesso mi accingo a
guastare le feste
dunque io vorrei cominciare ricordando
un personaggio scomparso da poco
questo professor bartlett che insegnava
fisica nucleare all'università del
colorado una persona particolare perché
ha passato praticamente tutta la sua
vita accademica ha fatto 1742 conferenze
dicendo sempre la stessa cosa
provando a lanciare un messaggio che
però cerchiamo di capire se passano un
passo il suo concetto era che il più
grande difetto della razza umana è
questa difficoltà a comprendere la
funzione esponenziale i processi che
dipendono dalla funzione esponenziale
ora noi siamo qui a parlare di
innovazione esponenziale ho pensato che
forse il messaggio poteva diventare
interessante per tutti noi
dopo queste 1742 conferenze del
messaggio è passato
siamo nei guai
siamo profondamente nei guai e non è la
prima volta nella storia che siamo nei
guai per il problema della funzione
esponenziale abbiamo avuto tanti esempi
prima di noi
il problema è così serio che a un certo
punto abbiamo cominciato a inventarci
delle leggende per cercare di tenerlo a
mente come farsi il nodo al fazzoletto
per esempio facciamo un esperimento io
non vi vedo molto bene ma quanti
conoscono la leggenda di sissa sulle
mani per bene che se non si vede
vero ecco perché siamo nei guai perché
in un contesto di persone che parlano di
innovazione esponenziale
pochi forse un quinto conoscono la
leggenda di si sa non ve la racconto non
vi preoccupate bene dove siamo e perché
dico che siamo nei guai
in questo momento questa fase storica
viene chiamata da chi studia queste cose
la tempesta perfetta perché il cumulo di
guai accumulati è veramente
impressionante quindi abbiamo il
problema climatico riscaldamento globale
ci avviciniamo a un grosso problema
energetico
abbiamo esaurito una enorme quantità di
tutte le risorse fondamentali che ci
servono
ieri ero in conferenza con un con un
esperto di agricoltura che diceva sono
finiti i fosfati sapete non sappiamo
come fare a mangiare nei prossimi anni
e poi abbiamo prodotto un debito che è
molto più grande della quantità di soldi
che esistono
abbiamo una crisi economica che più
crisi economica di questo l'abbiamo mai
vista e dal punto di vista dell'equità
diciamo non siamo andati mai tanto bene
comunque rimane una parte del mondo che
se la cava e tutti gli altri che insomma
più o meno sopravvivono il primo grosso
problema da affrontare che quasi nessuno
di noi si rende conto bene che tipo di
guai siamo
e questo ha delle conseguenze su quello
che poi facciamo quando facciamo
innovazione o quando progettiamo una
nuova impresa o quando organizziamo la
nostra vita
il punto è un po questo andreste in mare
affrontare un uragano con una barca di
carta cure veste non so un infarto alla
camomilla partire ste per l'everest in
ciabatte
sono tutte cose che non fareste perché è
abbastanza evidente che non sono delle
buone idee
e però adesso vi faccio un esempio
parliamo del clima e vediamo quanto
siamo connessi alla realtà termodinamica
del pianeta questo è un grafico recente
ce ne sono ormai milioni e sono
purtroppo tutti uguali la riga rossa li
indica la traiettoria delle temperature
sul pianeta
dallera preindustriale abbiamo aumentato
di 0,8 gradi la temperatura media è
praticamente siamo già al limite della
sopportazione i nostri sistemi non
sopportano già non so se avete visto i
tornado girare per l'emilia romagna o
avete mai sentito il sindaco di new york
che si chiede dove troverà miliardi di
dollari per proteggere la città
dall'acqua che si alza dove stiamo
andando
con i nostri processi industriali con la
nostra società stiamo andando a fine
secolo a circa più 6 gradi a circa più 6
gradi non sappiamo bene se ci siamo
ancora come specie sul pianeta ci sono
forti dubbi qualcuno dice ma forse in
qualche posto qualcuno può sopravvivere
va bene il problema è che dopo la curva
continua andare su quindi nel caso fosse
sopravvissuto qualcuno ci pensiamo poi
dopo che cos'è questo ma non sarà vera
questa roba aveva massima cosa stai
dicendo
se fosse così grave lo sapremmo giusto
infatti pare che non ci sia mai stata
una cosa nella storia dell'uomo di cui
siamo così sicuri con l'ultima uscita
proprio pochi giorni fa possiamo dire il
quinto report rapporto della ipcc
abbiamo ormai una quantità di dati così
immensa che non si sa più come fare ad
avere dubbi perché delle volte avere
dubbi è interessante
ora il punto è
ma noi la sappiamo questa roba qui
la domanda è voi quando vivete la vostra
vita quando progettate il nostro futuro
quando fate le vostre innovazioni state
reagendo secondo voi in proporzione al
problema che dobbiamo affrontare
e ve ne ho citato uno perché tutti gli
altri occorrerebbe troppo tempo ma sono
più o meno tutti così o è una faccenda
che stiamo prendendo un po in ciabatte
ma adesso mi organizzo ecco questo è un
po il tema che dobbiamo cercare di
affrontare che cosa è successo e che a
forza di essere nei guai a un certo
punto c'è stato un gruppo di persone
ispirate da questo rob hopkins c'è un
bel bel the talk che potete andare a
cercare e vedere così non ripeto le cose
che dice già lui nel suo intervento in
inghilterra che hanno cominciato a farsi
delle domande pura e delle domande
principali che si sono fatte è dove
sbagliamo ovvero queste cose che vi sto
raccontando non sono novità
adesso abbiamo più dati però la verità è
che dagli anni 70
noi sappiamo che queste erano le curve
esponenziali che stavamo seguendo marzo
e dice ma tanto non le capiamo anche se
ne sappiamo poi ci mettiamo dei guai e
infatti vedete ci sia un mese di valente
questo testo che in italia è stato
pubblicato con il titolo i nuovi limiti
dello sviluppo
in realtà in inglese sarebbe i limiti
della crescita è uscito in quegli anni
ha fatto grande scalpore e poi è stato
criticato in modo violentissimo poi
abbiamo fatto di tutto per
dimenticarcelo la verità è che se lo
apriamo oggi andiamo a leggere quello
che c'è scritto c'è scritta la nostra
storia però è stato scritto prima
quindi uno dei dubbi quando questi
ragazzi in inghilterra hanno cercato di
capire come si poteva tentare una
soluzione al problema era che in 40 anni
di attivismo ambientalista dell'equità
sociale del riformare tutto del cambiamo
e rifacciamo le cose in un altro modo
forse da qualche parte ci eravamo
distratti avevamo sbagliato qualche
passaggio perché
ci ritroviamo oggi con un mondo che è
come come se non avessimo saputo niente
quindi sette anni fa comincia a questo
strano esperimento molto strano molto
atipico e l'idea è di vedere se si può
far partire un processo di nuovo di
innovazione sociale esponenziale che
parte dal piccolo perché gli stati i
grandi poteri non sembrano molto
disponibili non impegnarsi in questo
tipo di cose e che riorganizzi il nostro
modo di vivere
oggi questo esperimento ha preso una
scala molto grande e diffuso in tutto il
mondo imposti del mondo molto diversi
quindi si sta sperimentando anche in
culture molto diverse una dall'altra ci
sono all'incirca duemila esperimenti in
corso sparsi un po dappertutto e come
ogni buon processo di tipo esponenziale
ogni giorno ne nascono di nuovi in modo
esponenziale quindi cresciamo sempre più
velocemente
quello che vorrei trasmettervi adesso è
quello che abbiamo imparato fin qui che
forse non è tutto però comincia a essere
qualcosa visto i risultati interessanti
che si stanno ottenendo la cosa buffa è
che il processo che stiamo utilizzando
sembra che funzioni nel piccolissimo
cioè nel cambiare la vita di una persona
che decide di ricollegarsi alle cose
importanti la sua vita anche
semplicemente coltivando una piantina
sul balcone di casa o facendo un piccolo
orto lo stesso processo portato nei
palazzi di bruxelles vini immaginiamoci
dei posti quelli dove non nulla cambia
mai
sembra produrre più o meno gli stessi
effetti vediamo dei cambiamenti molto
strani mo che non avevamo mai visto
prima
funziona così per ogni persona che entra
all'interno di questo processo abbiamo
capito che dobbiamo curarci di cuore di
cervello cuore e mani in quest'ordine e
facendo in questo modo il nostro
cervello ha bisogno di elementi di
attivazione e questi elementi devono
essere dati certi
abbiamo bisogno di sapere come stanno
davvero
cosi attorno a noi i dati certi però che
già ci sono nel nostro mondo vanno dati
in modo sistemico vanno collegati tutti
uno agli altri non si può prendere un
argomento alla volta ma bisogna vedere
le cose nel loro insieme sempre i dati
certi vanno presentati tutti assieme
cosa che accade molto dotato
i dati certi vanno scollegati dagli
approcci ideologici ovvero non possiamo
scegliere solo i dati che ci piacciono
di più o che supportano la nostra causa
ma dobbiamo prendere quelli che ci sono
e come sono
serve densità
ovvero bisogna creare degli ambienti
gruppi quanto ne abbiamo parlato oggi in
cui queste informazioni possano
circolare in modo denso una sola persona
che sa le cose in mezzo a mille che non
le sanno
fa fatica ad attivare un processo è
molto importante ragionare sui dati in
modo scollegato dalle azioni abbiamo
visto che per il nostro cervello è molto
utile dividere le due fasi e infine
tenere costantemente attivo il pensiero
critico perché le cose cambiano e perché
è molto facile innamorarsi delle nostre
teorie molto bene che cosa succede
quando si danno dati certi in modo
sistematico alle persone scatta la paura
perché se voi vi fermate a riflettere su
quello che vi ho detto sul clima vi ha
praticamente detto che ci stiamo
estinguendo
abbiamo pochi anni per evitare questa
cosa 1 non è che si senta
particolarmente allegro no
rispetto a un'informazione di questo
tipo e quindi quello che abbiamo capito
è che conseguentemente servono spazi per
le emozioni l'uomo è un animale con
un'immensa sfera emozionale la quale
deve trovare spazio per esprimersi deve
trovare accoglienza ci vuole qualcuno
che si in grado di ricevere la paura e
la gioia guardate che nella nostra vita
spazi di questo tipo ne abbiamo
pochissimi
serve anche facilitazione perché non
siamo nemmeno abituati a gestire la
nostra sfera emozionale e quindi abbiamo
visto che è molto utile che ci sia
qualcuno che ci aiuti a fare questi
passaggi e attenzione perché quando
scatta la paura quando scattano i
sentimenti scattano i nostri meccanismi
di base
corriamo a dare le colpe a questo oa
quell'altro cerchiamo il colpevole ci
sarà qualcuno che possiamo accusare di
tutti i guai che abbiamo combinato
ecco abbiamo visto che questo è poco
utile lo si può fare ma è poco utile e
non ci aiuta ad andare avanti non ci
aiuta a trovare soluzioni nuove e in più
certo serve una cosa che è stata spesso
trascurata l'innovazione sociale
richiede tempo tanto tempo per cui la
logica dei progetti di innovazione
sociale di 12 mesi della unione europea
è una logica e quasi sempre destinata a
fallire perché l'uomo non si muove su
questi tempi infine serve condivisione e
ancora una volta serve il gruppo anche
la gestione emozionale ha bisogno del
gruppo siamo animali sociali credo che
l'abbiamo ripetuto tante volte anche
oggi molto bene che succede se si passa
attraverso queste prime due fasi fatte
in quel modo
succede che tutti quelli che fanno
questo percorso
entra in una fase in cui vogliono
passare all'azione e anche qui abbiamo
scoperto che spesso quando passiamo
all'azione invece di risolvere i danni
li aumentiamo perché noi dobbiamo andare
a mettere le mani in quelle reti
complessissima e fragilissime di cui
abbiamo parlato prima dell'intervento
precedente e quindi è molto facile fare
danni anche lì mentre il concetto guida
che stiamo cercando di utilizzare è
quello di resilienza per cercare di non
finire tutti come i merluzzi abbiamo
detto nell'intervento precedente perché
i merluzzi spesso fanno brutta fine
allo stesso modo quando lavoriamo e
questo è un concetto credo che vi sia
familiare abbiamo bisogno di rimanere
aggiornati e questo oggi è un problema
continuare a ricevere dati
solidi e puliti informazioni solide
pulite è difficile in un mondo governato
dal mercato perché il mercato ci
racconta la storia che vuole raccontare
non la storia che ci interesserebbe
sentire e quindi è importante che
esistano le condizioni in cui si può
accedere continuamente alle informazioni
pulite e poi serve la creatività e la
crescita
la creatività è vittima di un'altra
storia che ci raccontiamo da parecchio
tempo e che ora di cominciare a smontare
la creatività nasce nella diversità
abbiamo bisogno di stare con persone
diverse di fare gruppi di persone
diverse non di riunirci tra simili e
anche questo aspetto va curato in modo
particolare la creatività nasce nel
diverso e nei bordi e poi come sempre
serve l'azione sistemica non si può
risolvere un problema molto grande e
curando nel solo un piccolo aspetto è
ancora una volta no competizione un
mondo completamente basato sulla
competizione non funziona fa le cose che
abbiamo visto molto bene questo
esperimento che abbiamo fatto per sette
anni abbiamo provato a utilizzare tutto
questo e abbiamo avuto delle piccole
sorprese quando si mette assieme un
percorso di questo tipo è vero
all'inizio c'è la paura ma alla fine c'è
il divertimento
chi comincia ad affrontare la vita il
mondo in questo modo è stimolato dal
fatto che è bello e divertente e
piacevole vivere collegati agli altri in
questo modo e questo è il motore che ha
portato la transizione a svilupparsi
così velocemente
non la paura di quello che sta
succedendo ma la gradevolezza di quello
che ottieni molto simile a quello che
dicevamo prima rispetto al gioco è quel
tipo di ambiente lì che si genera
attorno a noi e allora io non lo so io
ho visto gabriella uscire dal terremoto
dell'aquila e rinascere attraverso il
suo orto una cosa piccolina che ha
ridato forza a lei ea tutti quelli che
le stavano intorno ho visto attorno alla
mia monteveglio il posto dove vivo
rinascere i campi di grano antico che
diventano pane
sì che la gente vuole mangiare e poi ci
sono i capannelli in cui si discute
quanto è buona quella roba lì e poi ho
visto le contaminazioni grandi il
sindaco di bristol che riceve il proprio
stipendio in moneta locale a bristol tra
poco si potrà pagare l'energia in moneta
locale io non so se vi rendete conto di
che tipo di shift produce una cosa di
questo tipo
e poi assieme agli altri ragazzi del
transition network
siamo stati appunto nei palazzi di
bruxelles perché ci hanno premiato il
comitato economico e sociale ci ha
premiato nel 2012 e la cosa buffa è
stato che andare là a portare la nostra
esperienza ha fatto sì che loro
cominciassero a lavorare come lavoriamo
noi questa è una seduta in open space
technology che è stata ispirata dal modo
in cui lavoravamo noi quindi io chiudo
dicendo che forse forse non siamo ancora
sicuri però questo potrebbe essere il
momento in cui ci scrolliamo di dosso il
nostro peggiore difetto
io lo spero e spero che voi abbiate
voglia di provare grazie a tutti